the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today is about curve
plotting and actually I call it curve
plotting with and without calculus to
emphasize the fact that what we're
interested in is curve plotting and that
calculus in particular differentiation
gives us a powerful tool that is not
available to us at least in an
accessible form without the calculus
let's see what I mean by this by going
back to a typical high school type
analytical geometry problem for example
sketch the curve y equals x squared now
we all know that the graph of y equals x
squared is something like this and how
did we find that you may recall that in
the truest sense of the word the
precalculus approach really is curve
plotting as opposed to curve sketching
and I hope I make that a little bit
clearer as we go along namely you look
to see for certain values of X what
value of y corresponds to that and then
we locate the corresponding point X
comma Y in the plane of the blackboard
and what we then do is somehow or other
take a French curve or whatever it
happens to be and we sketch a smooth
curve through the given points this is
the usual technique the question that
comes up is that as long as there are
spaces between the points that you've
sketched how can you be sure that the
curve that you've drawn isn't inaccurate
in other words starting in Reverse here
let's suppose that these are the points
have happened to sketch for the curve y
equals x squared and by the way as is
often the case in our course don't be
misled that we pick something as simple
as y equals x squared I simply again
want to pick something that was
straightforward enough so that we could
concentrate our attention on what the
mathematical implications were rather
than to be bogged down by computation
but the idea is this going back to the
problem y equals x squared suppose we
had located these points and now we said
let's sketch a smooth curve through this
what would have been wrong
would say doing something like this why
for example couldn't this have been the
curve now again notice that in terms of
mathematical analysis not necessarily
calculus but in terms of mathematical
analysis we can immediately strike out
something like this for example notice
in terms of our input versus output this
says that for any real input since the
square of a real number cannot be
negative the output can never be
negative and pictorially this means that
no portion of our diagram can be below
the x axis in other words without
knowing anything about calculus but
knowing a little bit about arithmetic we
can supplement our knowledge of how the
points go by saying look at something
like this can't happen because in this
region over here Y would be negative and
we know from the relationship that y
equals x squared that Y cannot be
negative well you see armed with this
information we could say okay given the
same points here why couldn't the curve
go through something like this see why
couldn't this be that's what the
question mark is in here for obviously
this is not the graph of y equals x
squared but the question is noticing
that the this curve doesn't below the go
below the x-axis what's wrong with this
and again we can get bailed out by a
precalculus knowledge of mathematics
among other things
notice the rather interesting property
that if we replace X by minus X here we
get the same curve as before to general
generalize this result notice that in
this particular case f of X gives us the
same result as f of minus X now this
will not happen in general what does it
mean if we know that f of X equals F of
minus X well look at the relationship
between X and minus X is clear they are
located symmetrically with respect to
the y-axis in other words if this is X 1
this will be minus X 1 now here's the
point let's suppose our curve happens to
be y equals f of X when the input is
one the output will be F of x1 when the
input is minus x1 the output will be F
of minus x1 to say that F of minus x1
equals F of x1 is the same as saying
that not only are these two coordinates
x1 and minus x1 symmetric with respect
to the y axis but the outputs also are
in other words to say that F of x1
equals F of minus x1 says that not only
are these two points the same left and
right displacement from the y axis but
they're also the same height above the x
axis
in short this point is the mirror image
of this point in terms of a graph if f
of X equals F of minus X for all X the
graph Y of y equals f of X is symmetric
with respect to the y axis by the way
that's why we could rule out we could
rule out this type of possibility here
for example his x1 over here his minus
x1 and notice that for this choice of x
the points on the curve
I'm not szymek are not mirror images of
one another with respect to the y axis
in short even though we may not know
what this curve is supposed to look like
the fact that f of X equals F of minus X
tells us that whatever the graph is that
should be symmetric with respect to the
y axis this leads us to a rather
interesting aside it's something called
even and odd functions that we could
technically leave out here but which i
think is a good place to bring in and
the fact that there are many many places
in our advanced treatment that will come
up later where it's important to
understand what these things mean that
perhaps this is a nice place to bring it
into play so I call this on the side and
it's about even and odd functions when
we have the case that f of X equals F of
minus X that's the case where in terms
of the graph you have symmetry with
respect to the y-axis such a function is
called an even function and I'll come
back in a moment and show you why it's
called even though it's not really
important the counterpart to an even
function as you may guess almost from
the association of ideas is
an odd function now an odd function is
one for which f of X is the negative of
F of minus X C for f to be odd f of X
has to be the negative of F of minus X
now what does this mean pictorially
again X 1 and minus X 1 are
symmetrically located with respect to
the x axis with respect to the y axis
this height would be called f of X 1 and
this height here would be called F of
minus X 1 and to say that these two
heights are equal in magnitude but
opposite and sign means what that these
two lengths are equal but on opposite
sides of the x axis in other words his f
of X 1 now what's F of f of minus x 1 is
the height corresponding to this point
and the fact that these must be equal in
magnitude but opposite in sign says that
one of the heights must be above the
axis the other one must be below the
axis and if that's the case from some
very elementary geometry if F is odd
what it means with respect to its graph
is this if you put a ruler connecting
the origin with any point on the curve
if you extend that line that line will
meet the curve again such that these
distances here will be equal this is
called symmetry with respect to the
origin by the way an example of this
kind of a curve is y equals x cubed you
see if I replace X by minus X this
becomes what minus X cubed and minus
minus X cubed is X cubed by the way all
I'm saying now is what if I were to take
a ruler and place it here and let this
line go from curve to curve all I'm
saying is that this portion would equal
this portion by the way maybe you can
already guess where the words even and
odd come from
notice that when I dealt with y equals x
squared I had an even function the
exponent was
when I dealt with y equals x cubed
I had an odd function the exponent was
odd and by the way there are other
examples but for the time being
notice something like say y equals x to
the fourth plus x squared say if I
replace X by minus X
if I replace X by minus X I get back the
same thing in other words here's a case
where if y equals f of X f of X is the
same as f of minus X an example of an
odd function might be y equals x cubed
say plus X see first power over here if
I replace X by minus X I have minus X
cubed plus minus X that of course is
just minus X cubed minus X and that's
minus the quantity X cubed plus X that
when I replace X by minus X all I do is
change the sign here in other words that
would be an example for which f of X is
minus f of minus x by the way while
we're dealing with examples like this
unlike the case with whole numbers where
a whole number is either even or odd but
not both it's rather important to notice
that a function need not be either even
or odd and by the way if you think of
our geometric definition that's not too
hard to see namely there's no reason why
a curve drawn at random should be
symmetric either with respect to the
y-axis or with respect to the origin
fact maybe the quickest way to see this
is to put an odd power of X in with an
even power of X in the same diagram if I
now replace X by minus X you see minus X
cubed is of course minus X cubed but
minus X quantity squared is just x
squared and now you'll notice that if I
compare these two I don't get the same
thing nor do I get the same thing with a
sign change you see in other words this
is not either equal to this or to the
negative of this obviously you
understand that to be the negative of
this they would also have to be a minus
sign over here oh if we want it to be go
into more detail about this it is
perhaps exciting to know that whereas
it's not true at every function is
either even or odd every function can be
written as the sum of two functions one
of which is even one of which is odd I
mean just to give you an idea of what
that means
let me just write down something here
this will come back to be more important
later on but for the time being just to
show you a connecting thread here as
long as we're talking about even and odd
functions all I want you to see is the
following identity if you write f of x
plus f of minus x over 2 and don't worry
about what motivates this I just wanted
to show you this to keep this fairly
complete now suppose I add on to that f
of X minus f of minus x over 2 you see
notice that the expression on the
right-hand side is just writing f of X
the hard way see his half of f of X his
half of f of X the sum is f of X and his
half of F of minus X and I'm subtracting
half of F of minus X that drops out the
point is that this is always an even
function and this is always an odd
function and just to review the
definition so to see what happens here
all I'm saying is if I replace X by
minus X here what happens if I replace X
by minus X this becomes F of minus X and
if I replace X by minus X here since
minus minus is plus this becomes f of X
now notice that when you add two terms
the sum is independent of the order in
which you add them f of X plus F of
minus X therefore is the same as f of
minus X plus f of X in other words when
I replace X by minus X in this bracketed
function I do not change the value of
what's in the brackets on the other hand
if I interchange f of X well if I
interchange X with - X here notice that
since I'm subtracting look what happens
I replace X by minus X this gives me an
F of minus X now I do make the same
replacement here minus minus is positive
but now notice that if I look at this
expression here I've changed the order
see f of X minus F of minus X here F of
minus X minus f of X and when you change
the order you change the sign in other
words then all I'm saying is that when
we talk about even an odd
functions they play a very important
role in calculus and other mathematical
analysis topics that not every function
is either even or odd but every function
that's defined on the appropriate domain
is the sum of both an even and an odd
function but in terms of curve plotting
the main point is not so much these
extra remarks as much as what an even
function is symmetric with respect to
the y-axis and an odd function is
symmetric with respect to the origin at
any rate if we now go back to our curve
y equals x squared the fact that f of x
equals x squared is even means that
whatever our graph looks like it must be
symmetric with respect to the y-axis
now give or take how I've drawn this
this should be symmetric with respect to
the y-axis if it doesn't look that way
imagine that is that way and so the idea
is what well any knowledge of calculus
whatsoever what I was able to do here is
show that whatever the graph of y equals
x squared is it must never dip below the
x-axis and whatever the curve looks like
to the right of the y-axis it must be
the mirror image of that to the left of
the y-axis again this is how much one
can do without calculus and most of you
who are practicing engineers I'm sure
not only understand this type of
technique as far as the precalculus is
concerned but can probably draw curves
much better than I can in fact even if
you're not practicing engineers you can
probably draw curves
much better than I can but that part is
irrelevant what I want to show up to now
and this is what's important to stress
is that to get as far as I've gotten so
far I did not have to have any knowledge
of calculus the way calculus comes in as
I say again is a supplement to our
previous techniques for example let's
suppose we did have the curve drawn this
way we don't from this we certainly
aren't contradicting the fact that X
can't be negative
we're not contradicting the fact that f
is an even function but how do we know
that this is the wrong picture well
given that y equals x squared we can
easily verify that the Y DX is
to X knowing that the ydx is 2x
that tells us among other things that
the y DX and x have the same sign
in other words dydx is positive if X is
positive dy DX is negative if X is
negative in terms of geometry that means
what that the curve is always rising for
positive values of X and always falling
for negative values of X well you see
what that is a hint
I say aha this can't happen because look
what's happening over here or for that
matter over here here the curve is
falling for positive values of x and
that contradicts the fact that the curve
must always be rising when X is positive
in a similar way we know that the curve
can't be rising when X is negative yet
over here and here too we've drawn the
curve to be rising that again is
contradicted by this diagram so you see
the knowledge of the first derivative
does what it tells us where the curve is
rising or falling and that given is
another way of checking whether the
graph we've drawn this accurate or not
by the way it's not all quite that
simple and notice again suddenly how
step by step we strengthen our
procedures each time for example now
knowing that the curve must always be
rising when X is positive and always
falling when X is negative how about
this possibility for the graph of y
equals x squared you see this curve is
always falling for negative values of X
it's always rising for positive values
of X but you see let's take a look now
at what the second derivative means if y
equals x squared
obviously as we saw before dydx is 2x
and the second derivative of Y with
respect to X is 2 and 2 is a constant
which is always positive this says what
that the second derivative is always
positive now what is the second
derivative the second derivative is the
first derivative of the first derivative
that means the rate of change of the
rate of change well the rate of change
of the rate of change is called
acceleration so if the rate of change of
the rate of change is positive
that means that the curve must be
accelerating or the function is
accelerating and if it's negative
function is decelerating what does that
mean in terms of a picture and the
author of the text uses a very
descriptive phrase here he talks about
holding water and spilling water notice
for example here the curve would tend to
collect water whereas here if water were
poured on it
the curve would tend to spill water
holding water represents acceleration
you see that not only is the curve
rising here but it's rising at a faster
and faster rate
again more primitively in terms of
slopes notice that what not only is the
slope positive but as you move along
this portion of the curve the slope
increases as you move along okay and
what typifies this portion that even
though the slope is always positive it
decreases as you move along the curve
in other words holding water corresponds
to the second derivative being positive
spilling water corresponds to the second
derivative being negative returning them
to our original problem the fact that
this thing here is greater than zero for
all X says that this curve could never
spill water and that rules out this
portion and here in other words now we
put everything together we know what the
curve can never go below the x-axis it's
symmetric with respect to the y-axis
it's always rising when X is positive
and always holding water now you see
this is what I call curve sketching
versus curve plotting with the
information that I have from calculus I
know what's going on for each point not
just for the isolated points that I
happen to have plotted in the data for C
the calculus fills in the missing data
very very nicely now you see this does
not mean that I'm going to replace this
by my previous analysis by calculus it
means I'm going to add calculus as one
of my bags of tools here notice again
that there is a very nice relationship
between pictures and analysis and I'm
not going to belabor that point all I'm
saying is that if you add two
previous identifications were
identifications like increase means
rising I mean this if the derivative is
positive the curve is rising if the
derivative is negative the curve is
falling if the second derivative is
positive the curve is holding water if
the second derivative is negative the
curve is spilling water and again we
have ample exercises and portions of
this in the reading material to
illustrate the computational aspects but
again all I want you to get from this
lecture is what's happening here
conceptually let's look at this a few
more applications we're going to find in
subsequent lectures as well as in other
portions of a course we're going to be
interested for example in things called
stationary points a stationary point is
a point at which the curve is neither
rising nor falling in other words if the
curve happens to be smooth it's
characterized by the fact that the Y DX
is 0 at such a point in terms of the
language of functions to say the curve
is smooth means that the function is
differentiable and what we're saying is
to be stationary at x equals x1 it must
be that f prime of x1 equals 0 and the
importance of stationary points can be
seen in terms of a physical
interpretation we haven't used our
freely falling body for quite a while
let's go back to such an example suppose
a particle is projected vertically
upward in the absence of air resistance
etc with an initial speed of 160 feet
per second it can then be shown that the
height s to which the ball rises and
feet at time T is given by 160 t minus
16 T squared a very natural question to
ask is when will the ball be at its
maximum height and I'm sure you can see
in terms of this physical example the
ball will be at its maximum height when
the velocity is 0 in other words since
this is a smooth type of motion if the
velocity is not zero the ball is still
rising and if there's a lot though if
the velocity is positive the ball is
still rising
if the velocity
is negative the ball has already fallen
consequently if the speed is smooth
which it is in this case the only way it
can go from rising to falling is the
first level off and the velocity must be
zero but to see what is the velocity the
velocity is the derivative of the
displacement in other words without
solving this problem which is not
important here to find the time at which
you have the maximum height you simply
do what set the derivative equal to zero
in other words stationary points tell us
where we have high and low points for
functions and knowing where we have high
and low points is a very important
portion in curve plotting we'll talk
about this in a future lecture very
shortly in more detail but coming back
here to what we were talking about
before what we're saying in terms of
curve plotting is that where the
derivative is zero gives us a good
candidate to have either a low point on
the curve or to have a high point on the
curve however we should not read more
into this than what's already there
namely it's possible that you have what
a situation like this in which you have
a flat pole the derivative is zero here
but the curve is rising every place and
secondly there is the possibility that
if the derivative doesn't exist for
example if there's a shop corner where
you have a shop corner notice that see
this is a straight line this is a
straight line in this special case the
derivative is a slope of this straight
line derivative here is a slope of this
straight line therefore the derivative
is positive on this line negative on
this line yet the point is what at their
junction there's a discontinuity there
you see that the function is continuous
but a derivative isn't and at that
particular point notice that you have a
high point even though the derivative
doesn't exist at that particular point
all we're saying is what that for a
smooth curve for a smooth curve if there
is to be a high point or a low point a
maximum or a minimum and we'll talk
about this as I say in a future lecture
it must be at that particular point the
derivative is zero on the other hand
conversely if the derivative is zero you
may not have a high or low point it may
be what we call a saddle point the curve
just levels off after rising and then
Rises again and secondly if the function
isn't differentiable or the curve isn't
smooth at that particular point you can
have a high or a low point regardless of
what the knowledge about the derivative
is it is ok just a little buckshot here
to give you an idea of how we're going
to use this material a very related
topic that's also quite important here
is something called points of inflection
points of inflection are in a way to the
second derivative what stationary points
are to the first derivative in many
cases we are interested in knowing where
does the curve change its concavity
where does it go in other words from
holding water to spilling water and by
the way again in terms of a geometrical
interpretation there's a very what I
call exciting answer to this question it
almost results in what looks like an
optical illusion you see if a curve is
holding water the tangent line lies
below the curve if the curve is spilling
water the tangent lines of the curve of
the point lies above the curve
consequently at a point of inflection
meaning where the curve changes
concavity the tangent line on one side
must be above the curve on the other
side below the curve and all I'm saying
over here is is that you recognize a
point of inflection by what it's the
situation in which the tangent line to
the curve appears in fact it actually
does in the manner of speaking cross the
curve but here's a case with a line I
think we talked about this in the
previous lecture I'm not sure but we
talked about the idea that the tangent
line can cross the curve and we're gonna
cross the curve and still be a tangent
line at that point at a point of
inflection by the way if this is a
smooth type of thing in general what
we're saying is that for a point of
inflection to occur the second
derivative must be zero you see because
that means what the curve is neither
it's going from holding to
spilling so it goes to a transition
where it's doing neither in the same way
as with derivatives with first
derivatives the mere fact that the
second derivative is zero does not allow
us to conclude that we have a point of
inflection in fact let me close with
this particular illustration let's take
the curve y equals x to the fourth the
first derivative is 4x cubed the second
derivative is 12x squared the curve is
symmetric with respect to the y-axis etc
using all the given data you know the
crew
second River is always positive what
have you we can sketch this curve and
again in fact the uninitiated say this
curve looks like a parabola what do you
mean it looks like a parabola well he
says the parabola does something like
this - well what do we mean by something
like this I wanna mention a few points
here one is of course that actually the
parabola y equals x squared well if
these are going to crisscross very
shortly here doesn't make any difference
the the parabola y equals x squared has
the same general shape but with a few
different properties which were
mentioned a little while but the point
that I wanted to mention here first of
all is simply this at the value x equals
0 y double prime is 0 so you notice the
second derivative is 0 over here yet
even though the second derivative is 0
notice that the curve does not change
concavity the curve here is always
holding water the concluding remark that
I wanted to make is what is the
relationship between y equals x squared
and y equals x to the fourth or how
about y equals x to the sixth or y
equals x to the 12th notice that any
curve in that family will look something
like this only what as the exponent goes
up the curve becomes broader in a
neighborhood of 0 and then once X passes
1 the curve rises more sharply see what
we're saying is if the magnitude of X is
less than 1 the higher of power you
raise it to the smaller wires on the
other hand if the absolute value of x is
greater than 1 the higher of power you
raise it to you see the higher power you
raise it to the bigger the output
becomes but the idea is this notice that
the
exponent in other words how many
derivatives are zero gives you a way of
getting into a problem that will become
very very crucial as this course
continues and it's the idea of can one
curve be more tangent to a line than
another curve you see all of these
curves are tangent to the line what the
x-axis y equals zero at x equals zero
how do we distinguish between these
curves well it seems that some of these
curves fit the curve fit the x axis
better than others in a neighborhood of
the point x equals zero see the point
that I want to bring out as to why curve
plotting tells us things that we don't
learn in the ordinary physics class is
this if you study calculus the way it
comes up in most physics courses we
essentially don't go past the second
derivative why because in many cases
we're studying distance and the
derivative of distance is velocity the
second derivative of distance name with
the derivative of velocity is
acceleration right and we don't usually
talk physically beyond acceleration but
notice that in terms of curve plotting
the third fourth fifth sixth seventh
tenth derivatives all have a meaning
that gives you more information than
what came before don't be deceived by
the fact that in other applications that
you never go past the second derivative
means that there is no value to knowing
how higher-order derivatives are related
to plotting curves at any rate I think
this is enough of an introduction to the
topic of curve plotting and curve
sketching we'll pursue these topics
further in our next lectures so until
next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate